javascript notifications the
notifications API lets a webpage or apps
and notifications that are displayed
outside the page at the system level
this lets web apps send information to a
user even if the application is idle or
in the background first you need to
request permission with and then if I
run that and see it will request
permission I'm going to allow also you
can do something after requesting
permission if you put and pop up this
result and say granted because I say I
granted permission to this page for
notifications commonly you ask for
permission to display notifications when
your app is first initialized and before
trying to instantiate any the simplest
way to create a notification is like
this and then if I just take this out
here and run that you can see the
notification the top corner here
subscribe to J's nuggets you can't
always choose where the notification is
going to appear it's different on
different operating systems and browsers
to be thorough you're usually going to
do something more than just this and by
the way in Chrome the notification never
goes away on its own and some browsers
it will but I'm gonna have to hit the X
to make the notification go go away and
Chrome so here's a more complete way to
show notifications in a page you're
usually gonna do more than just what we
had here with just a new notification
you're gonna put a little more and I
want to I want to kind of go through
this so this is just a function that
we're gonna call to create the
notification and so first it's going to
see if when it says notification in
window that's just to see if the browser
supports notifications if it doesn't
it's going to give you an alert the
browser does not support notifications
but if it does the fortifications it's
going to see if it's already granted if
you've already granted if you're already
granted notification it's gonna run the
note
notify function which is going to send
up the notification I'll show you that
later
and if notification is not yet granted
if the notification that permission does
not equal denied if you haven't yet
denied it but you've also haven't
granted it it's going to request
permission and then if permission is
granted it's going to going to run this
notification function let's scroll down
to see what the the notify function does
the notify function which is called here
or here
that's if we want to do the notification
it's we have var notification equals new
notification and you can pass in some
parameters we're gonna pass in the title
of the notification and then you can
pass on these options in the options you
can pass in an icon that's going to show
up in the notification and you can pass
in the body text of the notification
another thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna make it so if you click the
notification notification that on click
it's going to open a web page here
Karnes that CC that's my website and
like I was saying earlier in chrome the
notifications do not are automatically
closed however in some browsers they do
automatically closed but just to be safe
we need to set it to close if we want to
make sure it closes by itself so to do
that we're gonna set timeout and we're
gonna call notification that close that
bind notification and 3,000 here is the
number of milliseconds the notification
is going to be up and notice that that
we have the use of bind here to make
sure that the close calls associated
with the notification so we can see that
this whole function is called notify me
so what I'm gonna do is just call notify
me and then we'll see what happens and
you can see the notification up here so
I'll just run it one more time because
we set to go in a few seconds I'm gonna
put this up to a little longer here and
you can see it has the image it has the
title it has the body of the
notification if I click it it's going to
open up Carnes at CC and a new tab here
all I'm gonna close that thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for links to
information please subscribe and
remember use your code for good